[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du skyco le
magazine qui vous raconte les aventures
économiques du territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et pour
commencer cette année 2023 nous sommes
devant l'incubateur de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines le ski cube depuis sa création
en novembre 2016 60 startups ont suivi
un programme d'incubation ou un
programme d'accélération nous allons
faire le bilan de l'activité du ski cube
et découvrir l'évolution de
l'accompagnement proposé aux dirigeants
et d'abord on commence avec ce chiffre
plus de 10 millions d'euros c'est la
somme des levées de fonds réalisés par
des startups passées ou actuellement
incubés au ski cube mais avant de
rentrer dans les détails regardez tout
de suite le programme de ce 52e numéro
du skyeko le jeu de société Inno home
squest a été présenté au CES de Las
Vegas à l'initiative une start-up
incubée à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de
2017 à 2019 il s'agit de chocolate
shipku qui company lancée par Étienne
Pouget et Alison club ouvert en novembre
2016 l'incubateur de 50 ans en Yvelines
continue de se développer d'année en
année en 6 ans il a accompagné 60
startups sur leur stratégie mais aussi
sur la partie financement le bilan dans
cette édition illustré par deux sociétés
ortix et affleya on commence cette
émission avec un autre cube 50 chinois
celui-ci est un jeu de société innovant
qui a été présenté lors du Consumer
électronique ce Show de Las Vegas et
bien c'est la start-up chocolate cheap
cookies Company qui a développé de cette
console de jeux en mode escape game
présenté sous forme de deux cubes le jeu
propose plusieurs aventures à plusieurs
joueurs et cette start-up a été incubée
ici au ski cube de 2017 à 2019 rencontre
avec Étienne Pouget et
[Musique]
je suis Étienne Pouget je suis président
de toute l'équipe compagnie
du produit home squest et je suis
informaticienne et je gère nos équipes à
distance à Lille
[Musique]
ma crise se produit home Quest qui a
pour but de rassembler les gens autour
d'expérience d'aventure audio donc
vraiment c'est une console de jeux qui
va nous raconter des histoires dieux
dans lequel nous serons les héros et
nous allons devoir résoudre une série
des mines pour progresser dans les
histoires et peut-être sauver le monde
et donc le mécanisme de jeu chaque
chapitre c'est un peu comme un escape
game on a une heure de jeu pendant
laquelle on va résoudre 5 à 10 énigmes
en coopération avec nos amis ou la
famille c'est un objet connecté il y a
pas besoin de wifi pour jouer mais les
objets ils sont vendus un kit de 2 et il
se communique entre
[Musique]
notre premier prototype il s'agisse et
d'un objet pour les Team Building et il
s'est déployé sur une table il se
déplier et se déplié sur une table et
sur Kickstarter et on a reçu plus de
1100 précommandes et en fait il y a 70 %
de ses précommandes qui proviennent du
marché américain qu'on va vraiment
essayer de lancer en parallèle à la fois
en France et aux États-Unis
qui a réussi en juin 2022 alors nous
allons livrer le produit pour arriver à
avant Noël de cette année de nuit de 23
des contacts avec la presse américaine
ça c'est plutôt très bien passé et même
pas que la presse américaine puisqu'il y
avait des journalistes un peu du monde
entier qui sont présents lors du CES et
puis sur l'aspect distribution c'est la
même chose en fait c'est assez fou mais
on a eu des événements où on a pu
rencontrer des distributeurs du monde
entier aussi
[Musique]
on est en pleine phase
d'industrialisation alors nous allons
terminer l'industrialisation lancer la
production cet été et livré à nos
premiers clients pour Noël de cette
famille on aura les premières livraisons
donc on aura des ventes en ligne sur
notre boutique et peut-être avec des
partenaires pour la vente en ligne mais
après en magasin les accords de
distribution par exemple on envisage de
distribuer avec nature et découverte ça
ce sera probablement 2020
[Musique]
2023 c'est la sixième année d'existence
de l'incubateur de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines le ski cube et nous sommes avec
le directeur du ski cube Jean-Luc mélo
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors quel bilan faites-vous de ces 6
années d'existence d'abord une belle
aventure c'est vrai que lorsqu'on a
ouvert ce site il y avait quelque part
une notion un peu d'expérimentation
puisque c'était nouveau pour le
territoire de Saint-Quentin et on se
rend compte que après cinq six années
maintenant de d'activité qu'il a toute
son utilité et qui qui s'est doté de
riches d'expérience au bénéfice des
entreprises du territoire alors le
principe de l'incubateur c'est
d'accueillir des startups pour les faire
grandir les lancer comment quel bilan
vous faites en termes de chiffres
combien d'entreprises vous avez
accueillies alors des start-ups vous
avez raison puisque c'est quelque part
la vitrine du site avec notre incubateur
dont on parlera sans doute mais beaucoup
d'autres projets et de d'action porter à
destination des entreprises en création
d'entreprise d'une manière générale mais
également avec les entreprises en
activité principalement autour des des
ressources humaines et l'accompagnement
en termes de RH voilà donc beaucoup
beaucoup de d'activités et l'incubateur
pour terminer sur sur ce sujet là
l'incubateur avec plus d'une soixantaine
de start-up qui ont été accueillies les
accompagner durant ses premières années
d'activités on le voit derrière vous
vous parlez de l'accompagnement il y a
plein de rendez-vous on voit l'agenda
derrière vous du mois de janvier puis du
mois de février finalement c'est un
accompagnement global sur tous les
sujets qui peuvent concerner le
dirigeant d'entreprise oui tout à fait
voilà quel que soit la nature d'activité
quel que soit le stade d'avancement de
de projet de développement de
l'entreprise on est 7 proposer de
l'accompagnement individuel collectif au
travers d'animation au travers de
formation au travers de rendez-vous la
mobilisation d'un certain nombre
d'acteurs économiques d'experts qui
viennent ici apporter leurs compétences
au service des entreprises voilà donc
c'est vraiment tout un écosystème qu'on
essaie de mobiliser pour que les
entreprises du territoire se développent
dans les meilleures conditions alors sur
les 60 entreprises il y en a encore
présent d'ailleurs on va rejoindre tout
à l'heure deux dirigeants de startups
qui sont actuellement en incubation une
en accélération au ski cube est-ce que
il y a des histoires qui vous ont marqué
des success story économiques nés ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
dont on est particulièrement fier vous
allez effectivement rencontrer
quelques-unes je pourrais en évoquer
d'autres comme l'Accord que
effectivement que vous avez déjà eu avec
lequel vous avez déjà eu l'occasion
d'échanger dans d'autres d'autres
contextes voilà des entreprises qui
aujourd'hui
tracent leur chemin mobilisent des fonds
arrivent à avoir une bonne relation avec
l'écosystème du territoire et si je ne
prends l'exemple que l'accord c'est pour
nous un exemple qu'on cite souvent parce
qu'il est eu un cheminement au-delà de
l'accompagnement qu'on a pu lui proposer
d'intégration d'un écosystème puisqu'à
termesse qui est une très belle PME du
territoire a pris une participation dans
dans cette entreprise est aujourd'hui un
acteur capital sans jeu de mots dans la
dynamique en tout cas dans le
développement de cette startup qu'on a
eu plaisir d'accompagner pendant
quelques années alors en 2016 il y avait
uniquement l'incubation c'est-à-dire un
programme d'incubation maintenant il y a
un programme d'accélération depuis
l'année dernière oui ça c'est
effectivement important puisque
l'incubation effectivement nous permet
de prendre les projets très en amont et
puis de leur permettre de se structurer
pour pour se lancer sur les premiers
marchés alors que l'accélération est
plutôt dans une phase avale où on
recrute des startups qui ont déjà un
certain montant de chiffre d'affaires et
qui ont besoin de le booster donc on est
là effectivement dans une phase plus
avale pour permettre à ces entreprises
avec tous les moyens dont on disposition
de passer ce cap qui est important et
notamment ce câble des premières années
de développement commercial donc ça
c'était une nouveauté sur les deux
dernières années de notre incubateur
alors Jean-Luc dans les prochaines
semaines il y aura de nouvelles startups
qui vont intégrer le ski cube quels sont
les projets qui vont être développés ici
alors toujours dans la double dynamique
incubation accélération dans la
dynamique accélération incubation
puisqu'on va commencer par la partie
plutôt avale on a par exemple une
plateforme qui va se développer avec
notre accompagnement pour aider les
salariés de tous entreprises à mieux
déchiffrer leur fiche de paye donc c'est
une voilà quelque chose de nouveau qu'on
va essayer d'accompagner très
prochainement et puis également dans les
newspace donc là aussi on a déjà un
projet en accélération que que l'on
accompagne ici dans la logique newspace
et on a un beau projet qui va arriver
ici mais un peu plus en amont et donc ça
fera partie des deux projets qu'on a
recrutés pour la prochaine promo de
d'incubation et en accélération là aussi
trois projets très sympas avec voilà des
thématiques très diverses puisque c'est
aussi la vocation de ce qui cube de
notre incubateur d'abord une vocation
très généraliste et sur les thématiques
qui correspondent aussi aux filières
qu'on entend booster sur le territoire
ou filière phare du territoire et donc
voilà trois projets qu'on a qu'on a
souhaité recruter et qui vont être
évidemment en phase avec la stratégie de
développement économique de 50 ans en
Yvelines l'avenir du ski cube ce qu'il y
a de d'autres programmes qui vont être
développés pour accompagner encore plus
les dirigeants d'entreprise après
quelques années on commence à avoir une
certaine notoriété dans l'écosystème
sacclésienne au delà francilien et là
très prochainement on va répondre un
appel à projet de la région pour être
labellisé avoir un label qui va qui va
être attribué un certain nombre
d'incubateurs franciliens donc on est
fier de pouvoir effectivement apporter
les couleurs de Saint-Quentin auprès de
la région
évidemment que ce sera Coronet de succès
merci Jean-Luc Merot directeur disciplu
mais justement vous en parliez il y a
plein de domaines d'activités qui sont
en développement aussi cube on parle
notamment de newspace comme vous l'avez
dit on parle de fintech aussi on parle
de d'automobile d'aéronautique et bien
là on va aller voir des entreprises
engagées à la fois dans l'agriculture
technologique et dans l'économie
circulaire c'est parti
[Musique]
c'est le porte-étendard de l'agriculture
technologique la start-up hortics et
nous sommes avec son fondateur et
dirigeant Olivier Ruchot bonjour bonjour
Nicolas
[Musique]
alors vous avez rejoint le ski cube en
2018 vous faites partie de ces startups
anciennes maintenant et puis d'ailleurs
vous allez quitter le ski cube très
prochainement puisqu'à la fin de la
semaine on commence à faire nos cartons
et on déménage à Promopole en
l'occurrence pas très loin d'ici alors
quel bilan vous faites justement de ces
de ces années passées ici au ski cube
alors un bilan qui est globalement très
positif parce que en partant d'une idée
où ça gère dans les dans le cerveau on
est tout seul à la situation à laquelle
on est arrivé aujourd'hui on a
aujourd'hui emploi quatre personnes à
temps complet en CDI et deux alternants
donc on est arrivé à une quelque chose
de concret commercialisé sur lesquels
les ventes d'écoles donc ma foi positif
et puis on le voit derrière vous cette
solution c'est scopique alors un mot
rapide sur ce qu'est ce que X en fait
scopic c'est une solution de traçabilité
agricole et la vocation qu'on s'est
donné c'est de mettre le numérique au
service des agriculteurs en apportant
quelque chose de très simple
en fait au travers de ce scopic on
répond à une problématique double une
problématique réglementaire celle de la
traçabilité et puis une problématique de
temps parce que les agriculteurs ont
beaucoup d'activités et l'enregistrement
de traçabilité ça constitue une corvée
pour eux et alors du coup qu'est-ce que
vous a apporté le ski cube pour en
arriver là alors d'abord
l'accompagnement de départ à partir de
passer de l'idée à un prototype quelque
chose de concret ça passe par un certain
nombre de comment dire de challenges de
discussion avec des accompagnants de
réfléchir à quelle est la valeur qu'on
apporte de réfléchir à comment on arrive
sur le marché tout ça fait partie de
l'accompagnement mais en fait pour tout
dire la partie la plus importante pour
moi dans la création c'est celle de pas
être tout seul c'est celle de pouvoir
partager avec des pères c'est celui de
pouvoir se confronter à d'autres
perceptions et c'est vraiment là où on a
un gain à venir ici s'installer et moi
je suis dans un bureau depuis des années
pour croiser du monde et c'est pour ça
aussi que vous faites le choix d'aller à
Promopole c'est une autre pépinière
d'entreprise il y aura d'autres les gens
avec vous c'est ça c'est un petit peu le
sens et effectivement c'est un élément
pour moi important ce partage avec
d'autres comment dire d'autres créateurs
d'entreprises d'autres entrepreneurs
effectivement promopoles ils prennent
beaucoup alors vous quittez vous allez à
promo Paul 2023 ça va être quelle année
pour Artix
à vrai dire ça va être la neige j'espère
du décollage commercial j'ai recruté un
responsable commercial et maintenant
quelques mois il est en train de
vraiment monter en puissance et
l'objectif c'est vraiment de faire 2023
concrètement une accélération
commerciale c'est-à-dire que là
aujourd'hui vous avez déjà plusieurs
partenaires au niveau France au niveau
régional comment j'ai des partenaires
dans le domaine coopératif agricole sur
les hauts de France l'est l'ouest
parisien et puis également un partenaire
avec la Banque Populaire sur le sud
parisien donc on est déjà on va dire on
couvre presque la moitié du territoire
objectif l'Europe
alors l'objectif l'Europe ça fait partie
des ça fait partie des projets
on se projette sur sur l'Europe
potentiellement au début de d'approche
en 2024 et puis si ça s'y prête si on
trouve un marché si on trouve des
partenaires pourquoi pas un
développement plus large en 2025 merci
beaucoup Olivier Ruchaud dirigeant
d'ortie c'est donc ortie ce
années puisqu'elle était incubée ici
depuis 2018 et qui a suivi un programme
à la fois d'incubation mais aussi
d'accélération et le si cube accompagne
aussi les startups dans leur financement
lever de fonds près d'honneur on écoute
tout de suite à nouveau Jean-Luc Moreau
à ce propos
[Musique]
le financement est un élément important
dans l'activité de ski cube nous avons
un outil spécifique qui est initiative
c'est quand on Yvelines et qui permet
d'amorcer la pompe en termes de
financement
[Musique]
c'est une structure qui était mise en
place par l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin il y a quelques années
sous une forme associative et qui
mobilise des fonds publics et privés
donc on a beaucoup d'entreprises du
territoire qui abondent à ce fond que
nous mettons à disposition au travers de
près d'honneur un disposition des
entreprises des porteurs de projets
initiative Saint-Quentin Yvelines c'est
aujourd'hui environ une cinquantaine de
près donc ils vont voilà globalement de
5000 à 100000 euros avec une moyenne
d'environ 30 000 euros on a environ 120
près
en traitement chaque année puisque les
durées de remboursement varient entre 3
et 5 ans on a plus de 97% de des prêts
que nous proposons aux entreprises qui
sont remboursées auprès de 3,50 donc
très peu d'échecs finalement
[Musique]
nous avons la société l'accord qui au
travers de la participation capitale
d'une entreprise d'une belle PMU du
territoire intermé sa réussit à lever
plus d'un million de d'euros donc ce qui
est déjà particulièrement important et
puis récemment qu'on pourrait Tings qui
elle aussi d'ailleurs avait bénéficié
le monde initiative 50 Olivier notre
faveur de prêt d'honneur et qui vient de
lever plus de 2 millions de d'euros de
fonds on a d'autres start-up qui
actuellement le sont en cours de levée
de fonds et on espère que ça devrait
bien fonctionner avec la près de 10
millions d'euros pour l'une d'entre
elles et on attend confirmation
l'Espagne dans les tout prochains mois
autre start-up incuber ici au sein du
ski cube à la rejoint l'incubateur de 50
ans en Yvelines en 2021 c'est affleia et
nous sommes avec la dirigeante et
fondatrice de cette start-up Dominique
renard Brazi bonjour bonjour Nicolas
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
déjà pourquoi avoir rejoint le ski cube
en fait quand on est fondé quand on est
fondatrice comme ça d'une start-up du
dans un projet entrepreneurial on a
vraiment besoin d'être accompagné sur
des domaines qu'on maîtrise moins c'est
mon cas c'était le commerce le marketing
etc et on a besoin en fait d'être
accompagné sur sur ces sujets là ce
qu'on est un peu un peu seul en fait
dans quand on est dans ce type de projet
alors afflelia est spécialisée dans
l'économie circulaire dans le secteur du
bâtiment oui c'est ça nous notre mission
c'est de simplifier en fait le passage à
l'économie circulaire dans la dans le
secteur du bâtiment et de simplifier la
valorisation des ressources sur les
chantiers de déconstruction et de
démolition donc on a développé akibo
c'est un assistant digital au futur
diagnostic PEMD produit équipement
matériaux de déchets en fait c'est une
obligation réglementaire qui va
apparaître
normalement
prochainement pour en fait faire
l'inventaire de tous les matériaux sur
les chantiers de déconstruction et
essayer de mieux les valoriser alors du
coup là maintenant grâce au ski cube
vous en êtes où quel est l'avenir du
coup et qu'est-ce que vous attendez
encore du ski cul parce que vous êtes
encore un cubé alors on a commencé en
fait en 2022 ça a été vraiment l'année
de la commercialisation et
l'enrichissement de l'outil donc tout le
contact avec les clients les démarches
marketing les réflexions business model
et là j'ai pu effectivement bénéficier
de l'accompagnement du ski cube pour ces
travaux qui sont qui sont vraiment
importants et assez compliqué et donc
2023 et 2023 bah normalement
en tout cas c'est les vœux là puisqu'on
est en début d'année de
poursuivre l'accélération et en fait de
passer l'échelle c'est-à-dire que là
pour l'instant la commercialisation elle
est auprès de quelques acteurs qui sont
plutôt pilotes et précur et après il
faut passer à l'échelle aller trouver
d'autres modes de commercialisation et
là aussi on est en réflexion avec avec
les acteurs de ce qui cube un
cuballiance etc merci beaucoup Dominique
merci c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi vous pouvez
revoir cette émission en replay sur
notre site Internet ou sur l'application
mobile à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]